metal gear solid 5 will receive another  update this week and this one will  include survival mode survival mode was  announced last year and it has teams of  six competing towards five match win  streaks to earn rewards you can play  survival mode 10 times a week unless you  have the cloaked in silence DLC pack  which allows you to play the mode as  much as you'd like the good news is that  if you don't own the DLC you can still  try out the new DLC maps in survival  mode cloaked in silence will cost you 3  99 and includes three new maps and quiet  as a playable character Konami also  released a chart breaking down the  animation times for CQC moves across  classes you can check that out in the  article or in konamis blogs in other  metal gear solid news all the Metal Gear  Solid games are on sale on PSN right now  including Metal Gear Solid 5 which is  only forty dollars on ps4 for more metal  gear solid news keep your eye droids  tuned in to gamespot  you